Voters in Kenya flock to the polls in the closely-contested reelection...
...of President Uhuru Kenyatta, who calls for unity regardless of the result.
In Switzerland, the United Nations Human Rights Office...
...condemns the Venezuelan government for the use of "excessive force"...
...against political protesters.
In China, the ruling Communist Party...
...celebrates the 70th anniversary of the founding of Inner Mongolia,...
...an autonomous region which has seen recent ethnic unrest.
In Russia, a Moscow court, bowing to an order from the European Court of Human Rights,...
...halts the deportation of a journalist to his native Uzbekistan.
And finally from India, an Indian defense official says...
...the army killed five militants crossing the disputed Kashmir border with Pakistan...
...and recovered weapons from the militants.